was everybody this is derek with new
media rock stars were at the district
lines signing t'en and saturday at
playlist slide we got the knife knows we
got Rebecca Black we got the Gregory
Brothers now we're gonna find out who's
the next new video rock stars hashtag
playlist rock star that's cool with me
hey guys what's up we're here at our
meetup at playlist live and new media
rockstars hooked us up in this awesome
cake to celebrate a hundred thousand
subscribers basically just get back to
everyone and say thank you for watching
so we really appreciate it and now let's
go be some people women cut a cake
that's our wedding don't magic back
magic ticket come you everybody this is
derek for new media rockstars we're here
the doc we're here to find out who's the
next new media rockstar hashtag Noumea
wait hashtag ah